all right hot breath averse welcome back
this is the hot breath podcast the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
this is our new series we're doing in
quarantine called comedians on skype
talking comedy this is the show where
you get to ask your favorite comedians
your favorite comedy questions if you
are listening to this on the podcast or
watching on YouTube you've got to join
our Facebook group there's over 700
members from around the world they get
to connect and ask questions to
comedians like today's guest who had a
brain tumor and then created a comedy
special about it this is a must-watch
comedy special for any comedian or any
real comedy fan it's going to change
your perspective of not only what is
possible with a comedy special but also
just what is possible in life so without
further ado please welcome to the hot
breath averse the one and only Kyle
grooms ladies and gentlemen good up for
Kyle everyone thank you for that nice
introduction man yeah spit hot breath
already mom would you come up with that
name where'd you come up with that name
man it's well we've been doing it around
five years and like back in the day I
was a big fan of NPR's fresh air and
it's just like I liked the quick hit of
like fresh air so I was trying to think
of two words together and then hot
breath it's stuck okay now you asked
yeah yeah yeah I appreciate you doing
this man from your from your balcony
this is this is great so I mean I can't
be inside cuz my kids are like screaming
and right now they're going nuts
yeah I'm grateful for you to take time
to do this because it's cool about this
timing Kevin Hart was just on Joe Rogan
talking about how his near-death
experience changed his entire
perspective on time and priority not be
interested to hear what what effects
that near-death experience had on you
I'm usually I'm always like I live a
positive life anyway mm-hmm but after
the surgery it's just my give a [ __ ]
level just kind of went you know like I
I don't I don't care anymore your name
is like you can't kill me I'm already
dead no I guess I'm a little braver more
fearless less tolerant of [ __ ] you
know mm-hmm and yeah that's that's what
happened with me uh I realize that you
know I can die you know what I mean my
mortality is you know two minutes and
it's possible and yeah I'm gonna be here
for my kids I want to see how you know I
saw but how close I was to not being
here for my daughter's you know like now
when I'm with them sorry no please keep
going keep going
that's like now when I'm with them I'm
almost feel like I'm dreaming like what
I'm having moments with my daughters
like I feel like I'm I did did you see
I'm sorry and with Skype I'm still
getting the rhythm of these of like when
is there a delay or when are they done
and when like there's like it's a weird
communication but we're still gonna have
a great interview but like I just did -
I hadn't heard you talk about this part
of it how how close did you actually get
in terms of did you see the light or was
there a moment of like wait I'm I'm
current I'm dead or like something's
happening like on the other side type
deal what I had was I had a seizure
which like once I started having a
seizure I was able to catch myself and
just breathe like I said okay all right
I can't control anything right now but I
can't control my breathing if I breathe
I know that like you know I'm alive I'm
okay so I just breathe it and once I was
able to breathe I was able to Center
myself then I started sweating profusely
and the paramedics showed up and I was
able to walk myself to the gurney
and then get on it and then go to the
hospital so it was like I was conscious
through the whole thing I even the the
joke I told in the my special about
taking my vegan food to go I actually
ate it in the emergency room like after
all that I ate it in the ER you know how
to make so I was conscious of the whole
thing I didn't have a headache I didn't
have any it was just that there was a
pool of blood on my left frontal lobe
which was a mess it was deteriorating my
speech and my movement my arm movement
my right arm my right side was done yeah
you said you couldn't even sign the
papers like in the hospital I had to put
yeah and what was the vegan food what it
what did you eat
oh I ate there's a place in Hollywood
Florida it was a vegan gyro it was a
gyro like yeah vegan gyro today I love
gyros you know and that's what I miss
about eating meat but they made a
plant-based one out of
seitan a song and I'm yeah it was gyro
and some fries how long you had been how
long do you have well I don't want to
say vegan you like you talk about in the
special but like plant claims yeah yeah
plant base how long had you been
plant-based probably four years at least
four years uh-huh and it happened
naturally you know to me and I was in
Cincinnati doing this show and I was
craving barbecue like I couldn't wait to
get my hands on some barbecue but one
side I did I had all her side dishes the
hush puppies the collard greens and I
had my barbecue chicken and while I'm
cutting it off the bone I was just like
seeing the tendons and the muscles and I
just felt disgusted and I became
conscious I'm eating a dead animal
there's like a carcass on my plate
that's probably been in the fridge I
don't know how long it's been frozen
they killed it it's it's not even a
fresh kill and I'm eating it [ __ ] I just
felt like a beast mmm and I haven't
touched me ever since I decided maybe
I'll go or maybe I'll be a pescetarian
but then even fish
and living animals just started it's
just art of weirding me out eating that
you know and then digesting it and it
and it sitting in my system at home I'm
digesting a dead animal
yeah you've sold a big differences yeah
are you are you plant-based - no no I've
got phases I'm saying you feel a
difference of like when you eat
something healthy versus you eat
something that just like makes you want
to take a nap you know oh yeah yeah yeah
definitely do you think that impacted
like your recovery within like this
entire medical situation like do you
think being plant-based did they say
anything about maybe that helping with
recovery or anything possibly I think
probably - what helped I work out a lot
like right following I go to work out
I'm like you know just because you know
I'm older and I want to keep my body
energy you know and how I work out but
even in the hospital when they had to
check my heart rate they were nervous
because my heart rate was it was like an
athlete's heart rate not to brag you
know so like when I went to sleep you
know they have you on a monitor and my
heart was just like whoo-whoo like they
thought I was dying but I was perfectly
fine Wow
and that's because that's what Kevin
Hart said when his was like if he didn't
have such a strong core then he would
have been paralyzed like the the implant
could have paralyzed him I'm sure that
helped Kevin a lot though definitely
with that kind of injury and being
physically fit yeah he keeps it tight
man you gotta keep it tight both yeah
and he was just one of like the
countless comics did like contribute to
your GoFundMe I mean you're trying to
raise seventy five thousand you raised
over a hundred thousand
that's got to be gratifying actually I
think the first thing was 50 or
something oh okay this was 50 and then
it went up to 75 then it went up then it
went past that you know yeah I was
sitting in the hospital like why I was
so freaked out by it you know it's got
to be rewarding though of like oh man I
guess
people do care type deal people care man
yeah yeah people care about me man you
know you never say you know cuz you
become family and you become friends
with all these people but you know
you're working and you have business
relationships but you don't know how
deep it goes and then I don't know I
guess it all comes back to you you know
yeah and every people
oh yeah that's important I think in this
business that a lot of comics overlook
is like actually just being a good
person to work with will get you more
work yeah yeah I don't do I don't I
don't treat comedy people like that
because I you know something else but
because of the work but it's just that
you know we're a fraternity and you know
you want to have good work relationships
and you know people are different you
got different walks of comics are
different breed of people you know and I
just think it we get enough pressure
without not being just being nice to
each other and letting you ego go mm-hmm
so you you you mentioned the the seizure
and I won't give away the story but I
definitely want to dive into the process
of creating humor around something that
is seemingly unfunny that was probably
what I was most lured to looking for in
the special was like how does he turn
this into comedy because on the surface
as you read it I had a brain tumor it's
like where are you going to find comedy
so what was the process of like mining
for like material that is like ready for
a comedy special on something that
almost killed you I mean the whole
situation if you it's like there were
funny things like I don't know becoming
like my when I started freaking out my
daughters were like freaking out they
were like Daddy I don't like this game
and then someone gave them a cell phone
and then they were fine you know see how
you laughed but that's like that's like
a little thing and then the paramedics
showing up and they had proud boy
haircuts and they were kind of like you
know and I was kind of like looking at
them they were looking at me you know
what I mean it was just like that's the
funny
the vegan food there's a lot of funny
elements in in tragedy you know comedy
and tragedy come right along with each
other
you know so what was I guess how many
deaf could be funny I guess it depends
on how you die but it's one thing to
tell the story of this happened but to
actually make it consistent punchlines
and really weave in the humor while also
weaving in the humanity which you which
you balanced beautifully within it of
even like you take us to the moment of
you I remember to breathe so the story
really takes us up and down so did you
oh wow did you first like type it all
out and then go back and start to insert
the punchlines like how do you actually
create it
no we film the documentary stuff and
then we film the stand-up stuff mm-hmm
and iíd really I knew okay I know I want
to talk about my family my love life my
wife and how that affected me because
these are the things that I almost lost
you know the and these were the people
who all was there with me when it
happened
so I wanted to paint that picture and
then you just hope that the video and
the stand-up works off of each other and
that's where the job of the editor comes
in my editor did amazing job man Darwin
Phillips it uh I copy edit post yeah
editing it because that when I first saw
the stand-up alone I was kind of like
hmm you know you gotta laugh like it was
hard to watch you know but then once we
started chopping it down and getting the
little pieces out and then and then
juxtaposed in the the dramedy the comedy
drama then it started to flow together
better so then that that's what created
my editors was part of what helped me
create that flow we just had a bunch of
puzzle pieces on the table that you have
to put together so there's actually a
lot of stand-up that I did I did an hour
an hour worth of stand-up in that
special which I'll put on my album but
not on my special it'll be on my CD
gotcha and not my special so the special
I wanted to keep a half hour
short and tell that story and then the
brain humor album will have all the
other like you know I do an Obama
impression I go you know I mean I'll
talk about Trump I do all that other
stuff that didn't have anything to do
with you know mmm-hmm
especially the the incident but yeah and
I want to get into like the joke riding
behind the incident in terms of like how
I like I like how you structure the flow
of the special in terms of the
sequencing of it it's where you kind of
like you take us through your beginning
middle and end and aftermath like you
really take us through the whole journey
but if we look at the story of you
taking us to the vegan restaurant and
you go through that whole story arc in
storytelling is something a lot of
comics struggle with so what you've been
doing comedy over twenty years I mean
what kind of tips do you have when it
comes to storytelling hmm with
storytelling I I like to my my tip and I
watched this from Richard Pryor's rhythm
okay Richard Pryor will tell a straight
joke a straight line and then the next
line will be a punch line and it kind of
pulls you through the story like it's
like I went to the store the other day
and then ba-ba-ba-ba that's the pepper
that's the funny and then and then you
go to the next straight line and then
you and you pull it you have to find you
almost damn there like a rapper looking
for a punchline you know it's like I
don't know it's hard to describe but you
you don't want to tell too much without
a punch of funny part right only see if
I could get an example like a lot of
part that I left out of that story as we
went to before we went to that
restaurant we went to another vegan
restaurant that was in Little Haiti but
the restaurant it was a food truck it
had no bathroom and my daughter was she
was like I don't want to eat here so
that I it was like I don't want to eat
eateth daddy
you know my daughter's bougie you know
basically so then these are the fun so
and then being a progressive parent
smear my my wife we chose to go to
another place but had it been my mother
she would be like no you don't sit here
and eat this food that we you know what
I mean so these are all jokes that the
situation is funny it's funny enough
she's just a lot of funny and then on a
car ride to this vegan restaurant my
wife was driving me crazy
with my driving you know what I mean
like because I was driving she thought I
couldn't join so I had all this pressure
building up on the way to the vegan
restaurant do you know what I mean
and I so by the time we got there this
all this already was I was already a
mess so then once you hear that story
where we went in we sat down with a bar
and and then we sat down but there's
funny all through that you get what I'm
saying
by just funny situations my wife
complained about my driving we got to
the place there was a car park - aw [ __ ]
that so I had to park please there was a
lot of situations that were funny about
that
so but I guess maybe for like economy of
words instead of saying we went here and
then drove and it got her upset you kind
of get that across with the switching of
the tables all of that like tension
building up to this moment yeah how is
that kind of the point of view you guys
switching tables is to kind of build the
kind of the stage within the
relationship because we chopped a lot
out just because it wasn't working with
them but yeah that because it wasn't
that the part that I just told you was
what we kind of left out because there
was a hole that the whole day was kind
of funny there was incidents that were
funny leading up to my seizure that I
took note of you know that you can make
funny situations but we chopped that we
edit it down to the best the most
economic parts yeah the story wouldn't
drag on for the special and what and
speaking of like the business of a
comedy special because I I just released
one in February and I'm selling it
through my website
comics are just giving away for free on
YouTube as well like what what was your
thinking behind Amazon and releasing it
via that way versus just throwing it on
YouTube or trying to sell it yourself
because yep if I did I didn't have time
to go for Netflix you know and I just
thought it was the next step down you
know Amazon to the next platform is
Amazon actually Amazon is damn near a
mix between YouTube and Netflix if you
want to get down to nitty-gritty you
know so I chose Amazon you know an
Amazon has that brand and it's all it's
all over the world and it kind of I
don't know I think YouTube I saw mark
Normand got over a million views on his
YouTube right it's just YouTube is is so
accessible I wanted to be a little more
ISS it's accessible but you know on a
platform kind of like Netflix yeah that
was my thinking with releasing it like I
self-produced it and all that and like
released it via my website cuz I was
like part of me was like I don't want to
release it on YouTube and there people
are seeing like mark Normand and Samer
elwood like millions and then mine has
like a few thousand and versi also like
showing comics that hey you can produce
your own special sell it you don't have
to give it away and you can make your
money back
like I was kind of trying to pave that
path as well oh I see but but if this is
your first special then yeah ten year we
released it on my 10-year anniversary
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah then you give
good to sell it and sell it after your
shows for five bucks or whatever I don't
know but yeah you know you're marking a
plan because this is my second
self-produced special my first one was
Miami nights that I did in 2005 on DVD
DVD special yeah
Miami Oh y'all may going go ahead I'm
a-goin put that on Amazon too but this
one I'll probably put behind a paywall
cuz my the this one the one that I have
brain humor is free if you have Amazon
Amazon Prime member but the Miami nights
are probably put on under like me charge
five bucks or something to see it yeah
you should I mean if people are willing
to pay to save your life they'll be
willing to pay to you know watch how
many special yeah such a great story
behind it too uh so let's let's jump
into some of these questions here shall
we so a member a member of what we call
the hot breath averse here his name is
actually Kyle groom singular well he's a
white guy from New Jersey so y'all have
we made it uh yeah what part of Jersey
Kyle would love to see what he says
but his insane he was super jazzed about
this and his question was let me see oh
he kind of he kind of did a two-parter
let's get to the first part first but
he's asking out what was the process for
putting material together from a
potential deadly event and did it take
time to get perspective or did it all
come quickly it all it came quickly
because you know yeah I was at home
recovering and you have time to think
about those things but I couldn't drive
for six months and I live in Miami now
so I had to get out to the open mikes
and you know Miami there's only open
mics that you can work in it at this
legit comedy clubs but mostly open mics
and in most of comics in Miami or under
fire is doing a comedy so you know I'm
professional hanging out in the kids gym
yeah but it's good we're building a
scene in Miami now and the glad of the
comments to get much better but I
started in September I couldn't drive
for six months so I my seizure my
surgery was in March I started working
on my material the end of September and
I just went out every every night every
other night in October November December
then when I in December I went to I did
it I produced the show in Perth Amboy
New Jersey which is my hometown
and I and I promoted it marketed it and
that's where I got this set on its loop
on its legs like I ran the whole hour
because and before then I was doing ten
minutes five minutes three minutes you
know since now I'm gonna try to put it
together for the whole hour in front of
my hometown crowd and this will be a
good start and then and then the next
rest of December I continue to work on
it and then I booked a headline week at
at the dead crow comedy in Wilmington
North Carolina and that's where I got to
run it for shows the weekend before we
should tape the special and I was still
I'm still you know because when you're
producing something and you and you're
doing the creative your brain is
slipping back and forth oh yeah you know
so oh yeah so the production and the
performance the performance stuff is
sometimes and you got to kind of be able
to your mind back when it's time to
perform yeah because you're worrying
about the lighting the sound you worried
about the stage sent the people your
guests the whoo-whoo
everything so but hey we did it and it
came out okay I thought it came out
great and you did you did two shows like
one in front of friends and family and
then you did a tailor in front of like a
general audience so I mean I'm sure you
got some good stuff with that variety of
audience yeah yeah that was producing
mine it was like even I walked out and
there wasn't a camera we have supposed
to be on stage set up it was
there so I was just like alright let's
just reset I'll leave it all in the
special but like it's the whole intro I
walk out and then I'm like this isn't
set up guys will you just come from my
first special but then you're also the
producer brain and it's yeah it is it's
something it's something I think I mean
with comedians now I mean you've been
doing it 20 years and you can we were
talking with she's 185 years 25 sorry
over 20 25 I did not mean to discount
those 5 years you you're you were doing
comedy way back before Miami was
underwater so it's uh but it is now we
were talking to Jimmy Schubert yesterday
on here and he's been doing over 30
years and he was talking about like the
power is now in the comedian's hands to
create their own success and I feel like
yeah people seeing in comics seeing
comics like you creating your own
special and distributing it yourself and
all that it just only makes it possible
for them to start finding their own
opportunities yeah yeah my friend marina
Franklin put put that uh put the battery
of my back to produce my own special
because she did one with comedy dynamics
and you know this is a budget and all
that stuff so she said hey Carl just do
it yourself bro you know what I mean and
I have production background before I
was a full-time comedian I was art
director a univision right yeah universe
yeah so I've worked for every network
NBC ABC you know CBS so I know people in
production I know you know set designers
on no camera people I know all of this
stuff so I'm like hey I'm not as well
you know hey put quickly put together
squad Nestle so yeah awesome
yeah great question Kyle oh and he said
he's from Woodbridge right by where
you're from like the bizarro
bizarro like you live Woodbridge as a
town next to me right we still I live on
the Woodbridge perth amboy
border gotta go through that's I live on
Gornick tribe yeah yeah helmet yo came
up together maybe
yeah Woodbridge has to go to Woodbridge
High School to study when I really
wanted to cuz they had good books Oh
had a good library of Woodbridge High
School you started from the bottom now
we're here now we here
Wow Wow what are the odds that's so cool
alright mark Mitchell asks the 20 year
of comedy he said what made you go
full-time and how long into your career
did it take
I started in 95 I went full-time in 2000
I started like on an urban comedy scene
and so I was able to like people were
headlining me before you know like if I
would have been I started in Miami so
there wasn't a lot of comics in Miami
that uh you know that just around and
they'd have to fly people in so they
people were booked me to headline so I
had to get strong fast and yeah and once
I got good enough to feed myself and I
sold my house and yeah I went full-time
comedy I can't even believe it now I'm
look at this must think I'm crazy I'm us
have been crazy to do that well you sold
your house to go full-time comedy like
yeah to get money for to become a
comedian to just not have the burden of
a mortgage while I'm trying to pursue
comedy and I said if I could just get
enough money to buy another house I'm
good but yeah I sold it and you know
just to live off of then for the first
few years and to get me Bob but I didn't
even really meet yeah it wasn't I'm glad
I did it
glad I did it yeah we all are yeah I'd
say how long in your career was that
because you were headlining like two or
three years in which is the three years
to like think about be on stage that
long def I did def Comedy Jam my second
year in comedies def Comedy Jam was in
LA
but yeah yeah it was crazy I couldn't
believe I was headlining that early yeah
and I probably my material probably
wasn't all amazing but you know you did
it pressure makes diamonds yeah can you
hear that yeah but we can we can hear
you though we can hear you better
oh good yeah let's uh we'll just a seat
your kids were running in and out we'll
do it we'll just run through two more
here
for Bo Johnson asks what is your writing
routine like what is your process and
how much time do you spend I'm not
writing it happen it happens organically
like when I'm home during the day just
cleaning and smoking weed my best
material comes when I'm alone and it
like you know I can be good enough then
I hit a little whatever just at home
during the day driving in my car
I don't have a sit sit down and write I
get an idea boom I jot it down and I'll
go to the stage with it that night and
just talk about it you know okay write
the name of the joke that loud no just
write notes like hmm just a little two
words of what the joke is but I know
what it is in my head and hopefully I
could I could remember it when it's time
when the people in front of me yeah do
you do you record your sets and then
review what worked and what didn't work
or what's the evolution when I was doing
my special I did that because I try to
be extra professional like you know I
want to I force myself to but normally
I really don't mm-hmm I really don't I
know I'm like jay-z I know my lyrics in
my head you know in my head you know and
I know word economy is very important
especially when you do a special so I
try to remember what words hear that you
know but even now I go and I look at my
stuff's was hard to watch because I
could have made those words more tighter
oh that's words I could have used less
words less words less worth less word
less words I feel yeah on that we're
always gonna be our worst critic though
I mean it's a killer special so I wasn't
like oh I wonder why he left that in
like it was it was tight throughout and
now a young comics listening I just want
you to understand this is coming from a
comic who's been doing it 25 years so
learn how to write jokes first learn the
rules and then you can break them but
this is a veteran who says he can now
just go onstage I've seen so many comics
go to an open mic and just be like I'm
just gonna figure it out I'm built I'm
jay-z and then you they just do that for
the rest of their lives like it's like
yeah learn the rules really yeah I have
to itemize what I'm gonna say here there
and then I go back and piece pieces
together with parts that go together
yeah cool I do I do notes all right and
this this is a good one to end on
because it is about producing a special
and let me see Oh what is this is a good
one just about real quick like how often
should a comment be performing do you
think every every when I was there was a
time I was on stage every night yes like
this is the longest I've been off sick I
mean last year was the long as I've been
on stage because of my surgery but this
is the long as I've been on stage I
don't even know what I'm gonna do when I
perform I got a show tonight online that
I've never done online comedy I've never
tried it I've never but I'm gonna try it
for five minutes
mm-hmm even though I'm opposed to it but
I'm just gonna tell a story
yeah yeah yeah and if your if your town
only has like one or two open mics do
you say like moves start your own like
just travel like how to maximize that
stage time yeah you got a move bro you
got a move you can't you got to get on
stage especially when you just started
and trying to get into rhythm and get
comfortable being in front of people and
making a room full of strength and just
well after the comedy club has to be
like I used to go to time to improv when
I was hosting this when I really first
started and I would throw my jacket over
here it was like home to me you know I
would yeah I would do out with seat
people I was doing all kinds of stuff
there wasn't even it was like my house
in front of me I was at home at the
comedy club you live in it live in it
you know even my mom my wife now she had
to accept I'm going out to do comedy she
don't even ask me question you're going
out now yes mm-hmm
but wait yes this is what you signed up
for I'm going to Miami so then now I
have to even be more on my game because
I don't get to see comics hula or a list
you know top shelf comics so now I have
to comfort I'm back in the I don't know
the D leagues or whatever but it's like
you know it's like going down to a minor
league feels I'm playing with you know
I'm playing in the minors again sure but
still trying to keep a major major skill
yeah for sure yeah that is that's that's
a benefit of being in like a New York is
you you get around the best so it only
elevates your skill as well yeah now I'm
really looking to see what people are
talking about people that you know like
wow okay yeah alright so let's do the
final one here from Robin Sutton Clark
who says uh besides comedians who should
we assemble as a power production team
like is it mixers producers editors like
what is the team behind it the team I
got a good cinematographer you actually
need it all you need a good lighting
person because the lighting is very
important for a special
Audio audio number one it has to sound
good that's that's things I heart on
like I might make sure the sound is all
right you know and yeah you have to get
when you shoot especially you have to
get the whole whole team I had to get a
venue and then the venue was you know
it's just a black box theater so then I
had to dress dress to stay the stage the
set I even put vinyl on the floor
because the floor was kind of it was a
stage floor a dusty dirty so I'll put
that nice you know semi-gloss vinyl on
the floor awesome yeah
so as we land this plane here is there
any this is you know a comedy education
platform is there is there any advice
you've found over the years to be like
the most helpful to you or something you
always fall back on when times are tough
and comedy like is there any advice you
could leave us with here always for me I
always study comedy like Bob Newhart
Bill Cosby anybody you think you not
into just comedy you don't amazing [ __ ]
I go back to Eddie Cantor you don't have
you can throw people who don't even
young comics don't even then are you
don't even know who Richard Pryor is
Dick Gregory Bill Hicks yeah this is you
you have to be a student of it you see
how did it like in the more you the more
you the going get into it the more you
understand like I didn't know just I
couldn't even know how to listen to I
listen to Richard Pryor differently now
25 years in the game then I did two
years in the game my ears are different
for comms like oh I see what he's doing
like there's a comedy specially with
Richard Pryor I think it was Richard
Pryor here and now alive where he was
doing crowd work where because what
happened was he was shooting his special
and I guess Patti LaBelle had opened for
him and they went and took a break he
started his company coming in after the
break you know that's when he started a
special like you doing that you know
fixing your camera guy that's basically
what Richard Pryor did on his special he
started with crowd work but I didn't
even notice that when I was in now I'm
like holy [ __ ] yeah I work in the
beginning of his special it hit
different when you are shooting a
special and now you know what that was
all about you know like wow awesome so
always be a student yeah that's that's
what that's what we're all here we're
always looking to learn from the best
like you so thanks for your time here
Kyle we really do appreciate it
oh thank you so where where yeah where
can people support please let people
know like where they can support the
special follow you all of that good jazz
well if they go to Amazon Prime video
you can see my special brain humor you
can follow me on IG Instagram I'm always
on Instagram you know Facebook whatever
but yeah mostly I'm on IG awesome so go
Kyle grooms comm how grooms calm yes my
website go follow Kyle's support him
please it's this special is I'm telling
a lot of people are releasing specials
right now and this is like a breath of
fresh air on just the format of a comedy
special I think it's really and I'm
hoping it inspires other comics to think
beyond just like the standard template
of a comedy special and really start
pushing the medium forward hmm yes one
thing I wanted to do instead of just
being a guy talking to a mic for an hour
or whatever just to be able to and I'm
glad I was able to do that with you know
my situation comedy it's a tragedy or
tragedy at the comedy yeah yeah and
Robin said she watched it this past
weekend so that's great yes
go go to Amazon Prime watch Kyle special
I watched it twice I I cried the second
time I even left an Amazon review from
my mom's Amazon Prime account so hot
breath averse go forth support Kyle and
everything he does if you want to get
involved in more of these in the future
go into the description of this video or
audio click to join the hot breath
Facebook group and we will be back with
even more Q&A s tomorrow we have Jackie
Kashian Friday we have Tommy Davidson so
we will see you then kiddos adios
all right peace bro